and last year was that hopkins trade
that was the big offseason move for the
nfc west teams collectively this year
we've already got a trade ready to go 17
days from now 401 pm eastern matthew
stafford officially arrives as the
quarterback of the la rams jared goff
officially leaves the rams sending two
future first rounders and a third
rounder this year to make that
transaction happen
does
the
addition of matthew stafford to the rams
make the
rams the favorite they are the favorite
should that be the case plus 165 via
points bet is that fair in your
assessment when you consider the other
teams chris i i do i think it's fair i i
think you know
all those teams got a little work
seattle you know we know where they're
at the 49ers got a few moves they got to
make you know the rams aren't perfect
but damn when you just look at that
defense of course mcveigh's ability to
run the ball the running backs are set
up and everything like that
um hey the offensive line we know can
use a little work there's no doubt about
that too
but i i look at them as the favorite in
the nfc west i do and i think they're
going to be dangerous to matthew
stafford pulling the trigger out there i
really i expect them to be a lot more
explosive and i think sean mcveigh is
going to be able to open up the offense
you know
a few levels more just because of
stafford and his abilities and what he
can do
another encouraging development for the
rams cam aker second round pick from
friday state last year mcveigh had a
media session last week and he said
among many other things he spoke for a
very long time but he said cam akers is
an every down back
and i i think he's earned that it was
three guys going into 20 20. it's one
guy now in cam akers and and that will
help not that he's taught gurley or that
he's going to be todd gurley in his
heyday but that's when jared goff was at
his best you give matthew stafford to
back like that and he's never had a back
like that right man that that makes
things different for stafford as well
chris agreed i mean acres is nice they
got a nice compliment to him but you're
right acres is a guy that we saw can be
a little bit of a game breaker and can
do it all i mean run between the tackles
bounce it outside take it up the
sideline for 60 yards he's got
everything about i i saw him in person
at florida state was impressed with him
impressed with him the second i saw him
you could ask me and mike tarico a few
years back we were we were gushing about
the guy he's big time so you know that
that the offensive side of the ball and
then you talk about the tight ends and
woods and cooper cup
and you know the uh the the the kid they
took out of florida last year jefferson
vance right and they they're set up
uh vance excuse me uh
they're set up for matt stafford to take
full advantage of this offense and
really make some big-time plays on that
side of the ball you know i i don't sit
here and go hey you know there are
offensive line we know hey whitworth up
there in age could there be a few
improvements on the offensive line
certainly but there's not a lot of
offensive issues i have with the rams
when i look at them even with the
offensive line they go man mcveigh's the
master of managing a game and also
figuring out how to hide little
deficiencies within that offensive line
too that's where i give them a lot of
credit so i don't look at the offense as
a big thing for them this off season the
defense on the other hand
they got some work cut out for them here
on that side of the ball because of some
of the free agents they got
oh and because brandon staley's gone
raheem morris is in as the coordinator
so you've got transition again sooner
than sean mcvay thought he would ever
have that transition surely he would
have liked to have kept staley around
for another year or so especially when
mcveigh is one of these offensive
coordinators who basically abdicates
responsibility for the defense to the
coordinator i still have that image of
mcveigh sitting on the gatorade tub with
his his play sheet and his and his
microsoft surface getting ready for the
next offensive drive while wade phillips
was basically running the team he needs
someone he can trust that way yeah and
he will he'll be able to trust rahim i
mean rahim is
you know an ex-head coach
tampa of course what he did this year in
atlanta
and
he's going to be able to manage that
defense and let them fly around it might
not look exactly the same as brandon
staley and how they attacked it but
nonetheless i still think it could be
one of the top units in football on the
defensive side of the ball but there you
know they they have two marquee free
agents in my opinion that i look at that
go
how does this gonna work out you know
they're not in the best salary caps uh
you know situation as we know and
leonard floyd was special for them last
year leonard floyd is a a really really
good football player yeah he's not like
on on the average a 12 sacks a year type
of guy but wow can he do a lot and he's
awesome and all he's really really good
in all aspects of the game so you have
him
and then
john johnson at safety you know i talked
about him kind of in depth last week on
my my podcast mike
he's one of the five best safeties in
football for my money for sure can they
can they figure that out i mean can they
keep they got to try to keep one of them
certainly and i don't know if they can
possibly keep too with the status
they're at right now
yeah look that's the problem when you
constantly flip first round picks for
veterans that you have to pay big money
to
you end up with
with not enough guys who are working for
relatively less than what veterans
command especially if you have great
players you can only pay so many people
and when you are watching so much money
walk away yeah like brandon cooks like
todd gurley like jared goff it
exacerbates the problem and this was
something peter king mentioned on friday
and this leads to my next point yeah as
to how much pressure sean mcveigh is
under because at some point
stan cronky is going to start looking at
the numbers and looking at the return
and looking at all this money that has
been paid to guys that they are either
cutting or trading away and in the case
of jared goff even though it's not
obvious from the surface they gave up
draft capital to get that contract off
the books right at some point at some
point there's an awkward conversation be
had between stan kroenke and sean mcvay
yeah i i mean yeah and and leslie along
with that there's no doubt hey they they
they they play on the edge that i don't
know you know i love them because
they're aggressive as hell they really
are
and it is like every year how we gonna
make a move to try to win the super bowl
i love that aspect about them because of
that though and years of leverage and
doing those things like you've talked
about it's put them in a tough spot
there's no doubt their their one
you know saving grace
is that
they've been very good in the draft you
know even with the guys that aren't
marquee names you'd go
you know who the hell is this guy whoa
he's he's playing good for them they
just got so many of those guys around
the roster too to where
you know they've been able to kind of
prove us all wrong with the way they
attack it and and that's been
interesting but you're right they're
playing with fire they're on the edge
and there's not a ton of depth on the
football team and fortunately for them
they haven't had to deal with the injury
bug a whole lot the last few years
either
and the fact that they've done well in
the later rounds of the draft it creates
an irony and i do think the word
properly applies in this context as i've
said before i never know thanks to that
damn song but
one of the theories out there is that
they're constantly trading away their
first round picks because they don't
want to be judged
for blowing first round picks and in my
estimation
that is a scar from what they did with
the picks they got in the rg3 trade nine
years ago because less need was the gm
at the time so you never get you never
get killed for blowing your first round
pick if you take those first round picks
and turn them into proven players well i
i think there's certainly some truth to
that i don't i don't deny that
i i you know the other thing too i i do
wonder at times is just
how long or less seed and sean mcvay in
this for
you know we heard rumblings about sean
mcvay in the monday night booth and all
that stuff a few years ago
you know i know there's some people in
league circles that think he could do
the whole john gruden route you know
he's a psycho so he is the type of guy
like a dick vermeel or a john gruden who
can kind of burn himself out and maybe
may need to take a a step away from the
game at some point so that's another
thing that at least crosses my mind when
they make these moves to where maybe
they know something we don't maybe
they're like talking to each other and
going hey we're only going to do this
for three more years so let's just hey
let's go all in let's try to get the
hell with them
right let's just us try to win and see
where it goes at least has crossed my
mind several times
once tony romo got to 18 million a year
oh game changer in the broadcast booth i
think that's prompted a lot of coaches
and players to think wow i agree the
streets are paved with gold if you can
get one of these spots now good luck
good luck getting one of the spots but i
agree with you
mcvay has the opportunity
to
slide into a broadcast booth be kind of
like john gruden and and i don't want to
get too far down the rabbit hole but to
the extent that that we have some monday
night football games on abc next year
that's going to put pressure on espn and
disney to pump up that booth and it's
gonna it's gonna put more money in play
and you never know you never know right
i mean
jimmy johnson left the cowboys in late
april now it was different circumstances
but you you
somebody shows up to sean mcvay and
drops a pile of money on his desk that
is as much or more than what he's making
to coach the rams with much less work
can you rule out that he'd say i'm out
of here yeah i wouldn't rule it out i
wouldn't rule it out for myself i mean
at what point are you truly locked in
for the next year yeah i don't know
what's i i'd have to do the research to
see what the latest retirement or
resignation was for a coach into an
offseason it's one thing to get fired
like jimmy johnson kind of was
but you know if if this deal goes now i
don't think the new monday night
football thing would kick in until next
year so that probably wouldn't happen i
just think it's something you're right
we need to keep an eye on yeah
absolutely need to keep an eye on yeah
keep an eye on certain the matt stafford
thing's going to give him some juice and
i think he's going to want to see this
through to a degree so that i i but i
think it's something to they'll look
forward you know to a few years down the
road do i think that's a possibility uh
i certainly think you know
the the look of the situation could lend
itself to that possibly happening to
like what you're saying
yeah
uh
and and that means they keep burning
bright as long as they can to try to get
that super bowl win that they they they
almost got a couple of years ago and
they've still got some great players on
the team the question is can they pull
it all together can they get it done
matthew stafford definitely makes them
better nothing against jared goff
stafford makes them better the
expectations will be higher as we saw at
the top of the segment the
points bet sportsbook has them as the
favorites from a betting perspective
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports